la question agite les chancelleries
occidentales alors que le scénario de
l'invasion de l'ukraine par la russie
semble de plus en plus probable quelles
sanctions en cas de passage à l'acte de
la russe
la menace est lâché joe biden poussé par
certains membres du congrès étudie de
possibles sanctions visant directement
vladimir poutine le président russe tout
comme des membres de son administration
et de son entourage pourraient voir
leurs avoirs à l'étranger geler ou être
frappées d'interdictions de voyager une
éventualité qui aurait une grande portée
symbolique mais peu d'effet dissuasif
pour la russie
autres options mises sur la table à
washington
l'interdiction d'exportation vers la
russie de produits américains en
particulier des circuits intégrés
fabriqué pour la plupart par des firmes
américaines
de quoi handicapés grandement les
velléités d'industrialisation du kremlin
notamment dans les secteurs de la haute
technologie de l'aérospatiale ou de la
défense
troisième possibilité celle de frapper
la russie directement au porte monnaie
soit en imposant des sanctions à des
banques et des institutions financières
russes comme c'est déjà le cas pour
certaines d'entre elles depuis
l'annexion de la crimée en 2014 soit en
excluant la russie du réseau d'échangés
internationaux swift sorte de messagerie
instantanée qui relie la plupart des
institutions financières dans le monde
peut être l'option qui pénaliserait le
plus fortement l'économie russe mais qui
paralyserait une bonne partie des
transactions internationales
enfin le secteur énergétique qui
représentent 80% des recettes publiques
russes est une autre cible de choix pour
les occidentaux certaines compagnies
pétrolières et gazières proche du
kremlin sont déjà sous le coup de
sanctions américaines et européennes
depuis 2014 il s'agirait désormais de
leur interdire par exemple toute
transaction dollars voire même
d'exporter leur production un chantier
est particulièrement ciblé par
washington
mais la partie européenne dont 40% des
importations de gaz proviennent de
russie est beaucoup plus réservé sur ce
scénario
north stream 2 toujours pas en fonction
divise surtout au sein du gouvernement
allemand le gazoduc a pour ambition de
doubler les quantités de gaz déjà
transporté le long de la baltique de la
russie vers l'allemagne tout
ralentissement des arrivées
d'hydrocarbures en europe provoquerait
immanquablement une crise énergétique
importante